What are my limits,
what are our limits collectively and can
my physical expression of this inspire
other people to innovate,
create and do amazing things in the
world and in and other modalities and
canvases?
Well,
that's one of the weird
things about people doing
extraordinary things like what
you did is that you absolutely will give
other people fuel to accomplish things
in their life. Inspiration is so
critical for human beings. I mean,
I draw upon it from so many different
sources from David Goggins and a bunch of
my other friends,
my friend Cameron Hanes,
and a lot of other people
that are endurance athletes
and different people that
I've interviewed on this podcast.
But there's something that happens
when you realize that people can do
extraordinary things.
It makes you believe in the potential,
not just in that person,
but also in yourself.
Absolutely. I mean, you know, God is a
great example of that. I've never met him,
but I know I've personally derived
inspiration from that guy. I mean,
he gets out there, you know,
you can't run a hundred miles.
Like I'll show you like I run
a hundred miles. You know,
and he's pushing his by two
extreme ways or you know,
I love what he says
about the 40% you know,
I think about it a little
bit different in my mind,
but like what are those limits? I don't
know if it's 40% or 80% people quit.
You know, people quit that I can't. Voice
comes up and you know, he's proven it.
So as many other people have actually,
when you say I can actually,
when you don't stop,
you get stronger.
And for me in my own
story and my own journey,
I think that final day that finally
final 32 hour push proves it three days
before that, you know, I'm
videotaping all of this.
I'm trying to capture as much content
to be able to share with people of this
crazy weird place that's
an article by yourself.
And like day 49 day 40 50 like I'm
literally crying into my goal Probean like
I'm running out of food, I'm exhausted.
I don't know if I can keep doing this.
I'm just like worked. Right? But sure
enough, I don't say I can't, you know,
it's that for it was that 40% was that
50% that's that moment when I wanted to
quit or I should have quit.
But then the strongest,
most amazing moment of my entire athletic
career that spans decades happens
three days later because I kept pushing.
It's not like I rested for
three days and pulled that off.
Like I never took a rest day in 54 days.
I pulled my sled 12 to 13 hours every
single day and on the last day it was the
strongest as possible. So I think it
proves if we can push through that,
I can't moment, no, it's not going
to work. That you can get there.
And unfortunately, you know,
we talk about 40% with Goggins.
I actually think a lot of people quit at
1% they're sitting behind their office,
they're like, you know, one day I
want to travel overseas, or you know,
I hate this job. You know, I've got
this great business idea. But I mean,
they're like, but I can't, like I've
got no money to start this business.
I've gotten no,
this like when I first set off my first
world record in 2016 2014 I sat with
Jenna in my house, one bedroom apartment
with a whiteboard and we're like,
I'm going to see if I can set the world
record for the explorer's Grand Slam.
Something fewer than 50 people in the
world have ever done and I'm going to be
the fastest climb Everest come to now
like climb Kilimanjaro, North Pole,
South Pole, back to back. I hadn't
climbed a bunch of mountains.
Be Pretty easy to say I can't. Oh and
by the way, we have no money to do this.
We have no platform. I have like
200 Instagram followers. Like,
I mean I have nothing but we
just sat there and like no.
Instead of saying I can't, let's say
I can't, what's the first to that?
We literally get out our laptops and
I'm like going to like, we're like,
we want to build this big media campaign
where lots of people follow and get
pressed. Like we know nothing about. We
have no background this week. Google.
What's the difference between marketing
and PR? I mean we are literally asking,
Google don't most basic
of all basic questions.
Oh, but you know, we,
we continue to say like,
let's get coffee with our one friend
who knows something about this.
We should probably get a website.
How does one build a website?
And it goes on and on like this. How long
ago did you start this journey? So that,
that was 24 when we, 2014 when
we dream that up. This will,
the world record was just the
fact that years ago. Yeah.
So to see if I could set the world record
for something called the explorer's
Grand Slam. So let's come and tallest
mountain on each of the seven continents,
seven summits.
And before that,
had you done anything like that
or did it just been athletics?
So I grew up in Portland,
so I grew up like in the outdoors,
but like I mean to go climb Everest
at Denali sort of thing. No,
the short answer is I'm going to
climb a few mountains. You know, I,
it's not like I'd never
been in the snow before.
I'd worn crampons ice that's like,
and I had zero experience,
but like not even close to the experience
that you would think one would need to
do that and to just break world records,
not just do it,
but like be the fastest person to ever
complete it. You know, like I said,
it ended up being a hunter in 39 days
straight through to climb all those
mountains.
Didn't know,
I think we had a clip up a second ago if
something on Everest, but uh, but yeah,
I mean to do, to do all of that, it
started from this place of not, of, of,
of uh, believing I can. And
then, you know, it's, again,
it's fun to talk about the epic adventure,
but be,
for me it's actually fun to talk about
what happened behind the scenes of that
because what actually
happened, like people applaud
our success. Now this is me.
This is you. Everest walking across
the ladder. That's, you know,
about 300 foot hole a crevasse,
uh,
on the other side of it that you have
to go through to on your way up the, uh,
the Mount Everest climbing route. And so
your crampons or clicking on the, on the,
you're hooking them on the ladder as
you walk across and if you fall you die.
Yes. Okay. So that man,
watch this again. This is so
awful. It's so awful. Look at,
cause you're, you're basically
just walking this tight
rope on. Let me hear it.
Listen to that click folks,
I implore you to go to the Instagram
page so you get the full freak out cramp.
The consoles, they're tied
together to those ladders. Yeah.
Ty [inaudible] is compete the 300 foot
cavern over there. Oh fuck. All of this.
She's a us. Oh, and you're looking down,
cause you ever go on and we cut
the sound off at the Ed there,
but I go at the bear and I go because
like there's 50 of those letters,
but I was cheering every
fucking time I got cross. I
was like, yeah, one more down.
Woo.
50 Times in the Khumbu I slash should go
through that section a couple of times.
It's a very dangerous section
of the mountain. Um, but yeah,
I went about 50 of those ladders.
So when you went through Everest,
did you see the bodies?
Um, so I fortunately didn't
see any bodies up there.
Fortunately or unfortunately,
fortunately. I mean,
I mean I'm not like trying to see
that bias, you know, but they're,
they're more prevalent on the
climbing around on the north side.
The day that I did summit,
um, three people died, uh,
on the day that I summited.
So when I, yeah, when I, so the
set, the, I mean, talk about Evers,
I mean for me is a major setbacks.
It was the eighth of nine
expeditions in this sequence.
So I'd done a hundred days
of other expeditions leading
up to Everest to do this
explorer's grand slam world record.
I'm trying to climb Everest.
I'm exhausted from a hundred days.
I just come from the North Pole before
that Kilimanjaro. Before that, you know,
Albert's all these other mountains.
And then I make my summit push on Everest.
I'm not climbing with a guide or anything,
it's just myself and one Sherpa who I
met climbing in Nepal the year previous
when I was training for this.
And so it's just the two of us and we
climb up into camp for so ever says,
you know for camps there's base camp and
then there's camps progressively higher
in the mountains so you can get your
body a climatize and we get up into camp
for, have you read the book into thin air
by Jon Krakauer? Anything about it? Say,
okay, there's a famous book
that's written about it.
We're 11 people die and right in this
moment it's called the death zone where
you enter above 26,000 feet. The human
body basically can't survive for long,
even with supplemental oxygen and this
massive snow storm and wind storm blows
in like kind of out of nowhere. And
we're just trying to push for the summit.
It takes us two and a half hours just
to set up our tent and get inside and we
know like it's over.
Like we're not,
we're not going to summit Everest
like in this storm. There's no way.
So we just survive the night,
wake up the next morning,
still getting pounded by this weather
and actually have to climb back down the
mountain. So climb back down the
mountain all the way to camp two.
And they're looking, they're
like, well that's probably it.
Like you don't usually like spend a night
out in the death zone and like make a
second attempt and you've already
tried all these other mountains.
You're a hundred plus days in
this journey. And I was like, man,
I want to see if I can get back up there.
Like,
and this other guy who I met on another
team had some supplemental oxygen.
So I had to use some of
my supplement auction.
So my supplies tours are limited
now as well. And so he, uh,
he says to me, Hey, I'm not
going to go up. I'm sick.
But if you get back up to
camp four, there's a couple
of bottles of oxygen that,
um, you could use of mine if you,
if you somehow get back up there.
So sure enough per sang [inaudible]
name of the shirt palace,
common with amazing climber himself.
We get back up to camp four
and the death zone. And uh,
we decided we're going to go for the
summit and we call back down to base camp.
What's the weather forecast?
And they're like, well,
it's the exact same forecast we
told you before. It might hold,
in which case there'll be fine or it might
turn into what you guys just survive.
And if you're not near your tent and
you're up on the summit ridge of Everest,
like it's going to get like pretty bad.
And so we kind of go back and forth.
Should we go for it? Shouldn't we go
for it? We just decided to go for it.
But this crazy thing happens,
which is,
you may have read about this or heard
of this if you know much about ever is,
but basically no one climbed
Everest in 2014 or 15 cars.
A huge avalanche killed 16 shorters in
2014 that the mountain was closed in 2015.
There was a huge earthquake in Nepal
that shut the climbing season down.
So no one's even climb
the mountain in two years,
but all of a sudden because
of these weather delays,
I ended up there and there's a hundred
people going for the summit on the exact
same day.
So basically traffic jam on the worst
fucking place to feed a traffic jam
possible. So Sang Bodie
and I would go, okay,
let's figure out how to climb this
thing. And we leave camp. I, you know,
there's a photo that I
took for leaving camp.
There's all these lights up the side of
the mountain and it's because there's
one rope that everyone works to put in.
So everyone's using the same rope and
all of a sudden we're behind a hundred
people. And if you stand there,
wind chill minus 40 degrees.
Like we're going to get frostbite, like
we're going to not be able to make it.
And so Passaic Bodie and I look at each
term ago, let's unclipped from the rope.
And so we actually decided to, we
actually decided to unclip from the rope,
climb up all the way to the
balcony from the, the south call.
The death zone area was mentioning before,
um,
up to about 28,000 feet on rope because
we actually think it's more dangerous to
climb roped next to all the behind all
the people than it is to risk of fall.
You don't know those people. They're
like, and people work. I mean,
you're on Everest at 28,000 feet
and people are walking, I mean,
one step per minute sometimes. I mean,
it's, it is brutal. And so, I mean,
I'm walking maybe two
steps every 30 seconds,
but I'm like you saying bolt like
pasties people. Yeah. This is,
this gives an example of like,
so you're in it like the world,
the worst place in the world to be.
You know, it, uh, in a traffic jam.
As you can see here for this
photo, I posted, uh, that day. Um,
but anyways, I get up to this edge
and it finally, it's too steep.
It's too dangerous for us to be
unclipped from the rope any longer.
And we're like, we're just going to
have to clip in and settle in behind.
You know, we'd pass like 50 or 60 people,
so we're in much better place than ever.
I still have this one big puffy coat
has actually the same puffy coat.
I used an Antarctica, the big like
Michelin man coat and I'm like,
we're going to slow down.
I better put this big jacket on.
And so I take my jacket off,
I undo my gloves real quick to put this
big jacket on over me to warm myself up.
And I looked down and
my right hand is black,
like just black is black, can
be. And I'm like Holy Shit.
Like telltale sign of frostbite,
like Oh my God. Like it's same thing.
We've got school kids bowling alone, got
family fun, the whole thing. And I'm like,
oh my God,
like I'm going to route lose.
My right hand is Jenice still
gonna love me. You know,
what's my family going to think? And then
I don't say anything to put Sang Bodie.
I jammed my hand back in this big
gloves and I go, okay, and I don't,
I don't recommend this thought process,
but I go,
well if I'm going to lose my hand anyways,
wouldn't it be cooler to lose my
hand but also have summited Everest.
So how black was it? I mean it
was black, like black, black.
So yes, it was black. Did
you take a picture of it? So,
so the sun had was just still,
the sun was just below the horizon.
So it's like dusk and I looked down at
this point and then the sun comes up.
So I jammed my hand back in this club
and I don't say anything to present bone
in,
like let's keep pushing for the summit.
So we go for the next three hours and the
whole time I'm on I'm like, Oh my God,
I'm such an idiot.
Like I'm going to lose my hand,
my hand's frostbit and this and that.
And so we get up and we're
about 30 minutes blow Mount
Everest summit and should
be a beautiful moment for me.
Like since a little kid I dream like
summiting efforts would be like the
greatest accomplishment of my life.
Oh my God.
And I'm thinking like
just in this dark place,
but also haven't taken a single
photo basically. And I'm like,
well I got to get like a
photo or a video of, you know,
the famous Mount Everest summit.
So I pull up my GoPro to shoot a video.
I shoot this short little video,
which kind of shows this crazy
exposure that I'm on one side,
5,000 feet down into China on one side,
5,000 feet in Nepal and this
tiny little knife edge ridge.
And of course I have to
adjust my gloves again,
this is from the summit and I pull my,
I pull my GoPro out,
I have to mess with my gloves,
put it back in and I look at my hand
and I started going away from my arms in
the air,
go per se,
Bodie,
my handbag
back. And he's like, what are you
doing? It just so happened that the,
the glove warmers in my of clubs,
the chemical hand warmers had
broken open and the charcoal.
And the copper filings of the chemical
hand warmers had tied my hand flack.
Oh Geez. I was completely fine. Oh God.
So yeah, this could peer if you play it
from the top is me reaching the summit.
That's the SAG Bodie right
there. But uh, so when
I'm on the summit of Mount Everest,
top of the world,
no words can describe.
Wow.
So what did you experience any
discomfort in your hands forward?
So you're, again, we're talking
about a lot of this, this podcasts,
bit about mindset, which is
one of my favorite topics.
And like, just like we said,
you can convince yourself that
the salt man is fixing your foot.
Like I'm on Everest,
I'm at 28,000 feet.
My brain's not working very well.
I know that the weather's coming in bad,
that people are going to get maybe
frostbite based on the forecast.
And I looked down and I see my hands
black. Where does my mind go? It's like,
it's not like,
Oh let me think about this.
My hand warmer must've broken
open in this. I'm like my hand.
And it was weird cause I was like, I
didn't feel my hand getting cold. My hand,
like it was fine, but I'm on Everest,
my hands black. That means, you know,
in my brain I'm like, I have
frostbite. So it's just like,
it's a weird thing where you can
take your mind. Like a lot of this,
the positivity, this, my mom
went to the negative immediately.
Like your hands gone. It's
frozen off like the end. Um,
so what'll happen to the people that
died? Were they on the rope? Yeah,
so unfortunately that day the weather
actually did get pretty bad later in the
day. So fortunate I was able to get
down before the weather got too bad. Um,
but uh, the people that died that day, uh,
one slipped and fell down
these ropes over on Lhotse,
which is the adjacent mountain,
but similar sit sharing some of the
same ropes on the same route. Um,
and then two people died
from altitude sickness.
So basically either running out of
oxygen up there and not be on to get back
down to their tent.
I think those people actually did get
carried back down to their tents that
night and then died in the
tent that night. Some it's
called cerebral edema. Um,
which is basically your brain fills with
fluid from being at the high altitude
and not getting enough oxygen. And it's
a, it's a killer up there. And you know,
one of the crazy things about
being up there is, you know,
you read about it but you really can't
rescue somebody very easily up there.
I mean, tick to carry a human
body down into the rescue them is,
is nearly impossible. And I kind of
always thought in my mind, you know,
if I saw somebody lying on the
ground, like I would, you know,
summon the energy to pick them up.
And I was actually coming back from the
summit and I was on the South Summit.
So just below the effort, some inner at
28,000, 800 feet or something like that.
And this Brazilian woman who
I'd met in base camp, um,
named Tyce who I've become friends with
your in Nepal for a couple of months you
start talking to people, getting
friends with other climbers, whatever.
And I see her lying on
the ground with our head,
like leaned back in her oxygen mask off
to the side and I'm like, oh my God.
Like this is the moment
that I'm most feared.
Like somebody who I know is lying here
on the side of the mountain and I think
to myself,
I've got to pick her up,
I've got to pick her up and somehow like
carry her down this mountain and I lean
over to grab her and I try with all my
might to do anything and I realized I
can't move her six inches.
Like I'm completely exhausted.
Muscles aren't working.
Brain's not working.
So I do.
The only thing I can think to do is I
just wrapped her in my arms and I say Tice
like if you can hear me, it's
calling. You need to get up,
you need to get your oxygen mask on, you
need to start moving. Like please get up,
please get up. No response.
She was climbing with a Sherpa,
another guide right next
to her and they were like,
look like we're having
trouble with her oxygen mask,
but we're going to fix it like it's
gonna be all right. And I was like,
just kind of going through
this intense moment, Mike,
what do I do? How can I help?
And it's this weird, as you know, I, I'm
not proud of it necessarily to say it,
but like there was
nothing I could do like a,
it's just the most helpless feeling in
the world where you want to help the
common person. You afraid, I mean,
this person, I'd be a friend,
but if any human being is lying on
the ground in the snow, you're like,
I want to help this person get down this
mountain. And I was just on so close to,
on my limit up there, the summit, there
was nothing I could do. Fortunately. Um,
she was not one of the people
that passed away that day. Her,
her team did get her oxygen mask on her
and she actually made it to the summit
and back down safely. She went up,
she ended up going up from there,
which to me is like another
whole crazy part of that story.
But it was an interesting lesson for me
in like, you know, you hear these stories,
you can't move bodies up there.
There's nothing you can do the rescue.
And people have been criticized for not,
you know,
doing these crazy rescues when
things have gone wrong up there.
But it really hit home for me,
like how,
how hard it would be to move somebody
down that mountain from that altitude.
And so when you're up there, you
know, unlike, you know, Antarctica,
I was actually alone in Everest. Like
I said, it was pretty crowded day.
Like you're essentially alone up there.
Like if you can't keep putting one foot
in front of the other up in the death
zone, there's not, not a
whole lot that you can do. Um,
so the three people that died up
there, did they leave them there? Um,
I'm not sure with those specific
people because sometimes they,
you can get like a large team of people
to slowly lower people down. You know,
in a weird way it's actually easier to
lower a dead body than it is to lower a
live person because it dead body,
you don't have to worry about breaking
bones and things like that if you're
lowing someone over rocks
and things like that.
So I actually believe those
bodies are no longer there.
But there are quite a few bodies,
you know,
still on the mountain in particularly
the north side, the Chinese,
so you can climb it from two sides.
The Nepal side,
which is more commonly climb
where I climbed the Tibet side,
the Tibet side is known
for having a lot more of,
the body's still actually on
the climbing route for sure. So,
but for me on that,
I mean that day in a crazy way continues
on because I got back down to camp four
and I'm thinking I'm going to sleep
for the night rest and come back down.
The mountain usually takes a few days
to get back down the, at this point,
you know,
I've only got one more mountain to
climb to come finish my world record the
explorer's Grand Slam and I was
about two months ahead of schedule.
So if I had climbed Denali
in the next two months,
North America's tallest mountain up in
Alaska, I was going to set this world,
this world record that I was. And so I
called back home to Jenna and I was like,
I made it like I made it.
And uh,
earlier in the day when my
hands had gotten frozen,
I had actually had a heated boot warmers.
And so I turned the heat in,
my boot warmers up as hot as possible.
So I'm like, if my hand is prospecting,
what got my feet look like?
So I crank those up as hot as possible.
And so Jen is like, hey, like how
are you doing? Like you all right.
We've heard some reports over social
media that has been a really hard day up
there. Like, I'm like, yeah, I'm a
right, like no frostbite, no injuries,
like I'm good. And I was like,
well actually, um, I, uh,
I burned my feet and she's
like, oh, frostbite. Like how
bad is it? And I was like,
no, not frostbite. I actually burned too,
like silver dollars circles in the
bottom to both of my feet from turning my
boot warmers up too much. And she's
like, wait, let me get this straight.
Like you climb Everest, you don't
get frostbite, but you burn yourself.
She was like, you, your feet fire.
Like justice is a bad situation.
Um,
but then she goes on and she was like,
she literally said the
next thing you to me,
I will literally never forget in my life.
But she goes, so you're in your tent,
right? You took your boots
off and everything. You're
curled up in there. I'm like,
yeah. And she's like, well, uh, I actually
need you to put your boots back on.
And I'm like, excuse me? Like I
just what? Like she was like, yeah.
So we've been doing some calculating
back home and it just so happens that if
you can get to the summit of Denali in
the next, uh, week, you can set, not one,
but two world records. And I was
like, well, that sounds nice.
But like I'm on the summit of
below the summit of Everest.
How the hell is that going to work? She's
like, okay, put your boots back on down.
Now climb all the way back to base camp.
There's no time for you to sleep.
But then a helicopter is going to take
you to Katmandu. No time for a hotel,
no time for a shower. But an evening
flight is going to take you to Dubai,
to Seattle, to anchorage. And instead
of having three weeks to climb Denali,
you'll have three days.
But if you can do all of that,
you'll set another world
record like ready, go. Oh.
So I was in disbelief, but uh,
no one better than to disobey.
Not only my amazing wife,
but the planner and logistics expert
in running the backend. All of this,
I assure enough, put my
boots back on, wipe the slate
clean, and found myself, um,
you know, just a hundred hours after
standing on the summit of Everest,
I found myself over in Alaska trying
to push up to the summit to, uh,
to try to set the two world
records and not just the one.